in the coming hours let's move on to
what else is happening in the world uh
right now NATO peacekeeping soldiers
have formed security barricades around
three town halls in Northern Kosovo
police fired tear gas and ethnic serbs
who were protesting against ethnic
Albanian Mayors taking office kosovan
police also guarding the buildings the
Mayors were elected in April a pole
boycotted by ethnic serbs who make up
the majority in that part of Kosovo
let's go live now to Northern Kosovo
altazira's Assad baig is there Assad
where are you what's happening there
right now
so we're in South Metro we're about uh
10 minutes away from zavechan where
you've been seeing pictures of those
clashes between ethnic serves and the
Kosovo police but we're also hearing and
seeing pictures of them clashing with
the NATO forces there now we were there
earlier in the day the situation was
tense some cars were being vandalized by
those protesters the police vehicles
were spray painted and the protesters
were singing along with nationalistic
sons and really trying to confront the
police but earlier in the morning what
they tried to do was take over that
municipality building now it seems like
the police were caught slightly off off
guard this morning they pushed them back
and used gas to get them to disperse but
so many people were there and when the
NATO's NATO officials tried to talk with
these politicians and said we want you
to get these people to disperse off the
streets the response from the sir
politician was that if I ask these
people to to move it will not
de-escalate the situation but right now
what we're seeing is that the situation
has escalated despite what kosovo's
international Partners have been saying
the United States the UK Germany the EU
have condemned uh Kosovo and its police
for trying to take over those
municipality buildings but if you speak
to the customer authorities here they
say they have a right to uphold the
Constitution that that election did
happen and even though there was a very
low turnout less than 3.5 percent those
Mayors were democratically elected and
they have the right to take office but
in the Northern areas the serbs do make
up a majority and they don't want to see
those Mayors take up office and they've
been trying to block them and that's
what we're seeing now this is what the
situation stems from now to Serious
Assad live in northern Kosovo many
things indeed to Assad